the question today is what one thing do
you think that country's companies or
individuals must do to make the world a
better place in 2008 well I think they
should concentrate on the neglected
areas of the world which do not get the
attention they should have ranging from
let us say Darfur to the Horn of Africa
to parts of the subcontinent which are
outside the mainstream they may trade
links from a trade length of information
called policy because they don't chain
to be beneficial at this moment but they
have a way Venturi imposing themselves
on consciousness through things that
happen that affect things you know so
therefore I think it serve a careful
survey to pick out not precisely the
hottest and most urgent places which
must be done which is crucial and
obvious but that's the problem
it's to us and therefore it's the a
great exercise would be to say what are
the most urgent and neglected we should
come don't you think
and wide exposures is one step actually
to address the problem so we need to get
the neglected issues out into the maze
here well I think the matter the mass
media tends to follow events rather than
lead it's very usual that they take the
lead and send people to places that are
so when we'll go out or not particularly
in the major focus and the media tend to
follow the great Des Moines and the
public gestures of the worthy and a
world leaders have great power in that
one little thought for is enough